You're from northern Idaho
Yup
You moved to Northern California
And now you go to high school there
And you have come down here today to ask us
Questions about what?
I'm Zachary, for - Hey Carmichael
Hey man
This is the official Zachary Rogers --
The official Zachary Rogers interview
We're gonna ask you as many questions
As you ask us, maybe some of them will be the same
Ok
And then hopefully in that process we'll be able to answer
Some questions about what we do, how we do it, and why we do it
But, uh there's a lot of wardrobe
I remember watching the video when it was organized
Surprisingly, a lot of people don't know this, pro tip -
If you wanna make somebody look like they fell super hard
Throw them into cardboard boxes
Ambiguous cubes
*laughter* Ambiguous cubes
Then you throw a camo - all you need is cardboard boxes
And a camo net and you just -
Bad guy city
Zachary, what are your thoughts here
It's just - It's stacked
Just, like, every single space on here is just filled with a gun
-Seems small, in the videos
[Camera] It is small
[Zachary] It's SO small
[Jake] And this is the prop room
[Zachary] Yup
It is just - there is SO much
This is where we keep all of our boom boom stuff
Yeah
Ya never know when you need a flame bar
Uh, and the kitchen
Sometimes, yeah, I'm just stood up here with a Nerf gun
And I like to, y'know, shoot at -
[Zachary] There's like Nerf guns, like, strategically placed, like -
[Jake] Yeah cos' you never know who's gonna come through that door
[Zachary] Yeah
Yeah, what's up bitch!?
We got force fields!
Right!? What's up man!?
It's impenetrable!
*Niko maniacally laughing*
AH NO!
*Enrique Iglesias' Hero plays*
We can just sit in chairs
This is a Niko mess
This is a CLASSIC
CLASSIC
Niko move right here
Here ya go, you wanna see what's in here?
Classic Niko fashion
He takes out a table
All the cameras
And a buncha other stuff
Now, granted, he shot a video that got 200k views
With this equipment
Two weeks ago
But
It's still here
For everyone out there who wants to go from
Film maker buff or amatuer film maker
Or film student
To making a career
Making videos on YouTube
We're gonna talk about that right now
So we're gonna answer, once and for all,
What it's like
Being Digi-Filmmakers
Chaaaange into Digital Champions
Tooooooo save the Digital World
Influe- Digital Influencers
I'm not gonna ****ing say influencer
Who you are
What you do right now
And why you came down here
Alright *clap*
So my name is Zachary Rogers
I live in Auburn, California
Which is about 40 miles North East of Sacramento
I go to *unintelligible* high school
And I'm the director of photography for our advanced
TV production class
When I was a kid I was mystified by movies
And you know where you're going?
You're planning on going to film school...?
Or are you still searching?
I've kinda pulled it together in the past few weeks
Of what exactly, like, my plan
Plan for graduation is
And what I've come up with so far is I'm gonna go to
LACC, Los Angeles City College
And they have a film course there
It's kinda like a poor mans UCLA
And get a certificate of cinema and TV production
So I'll just be taking
Movie making classes 20 hours - 25 hours a week
Then the time I'm not doing that I can be working on set
Trying to get internships or just working a 9-5 job
How many videos would you say you've completed up to this point?
Around ten. Maybe fifteen.
It seems like... bad
Right, you don't know what you're doing
Yeah, exactly
That's how you find out.
Yeah
So is that the first lesson?
It is.
Just pick up a camera and start shooting?
Yup
Is that you too
Can be a digi-maker
What part of working in this field do you find most satisfying?
I think when you have the opportunity to
Get feedback from people that are watching your stuff
And they're giving you
Unbiased feedback
One of my favorite things is
After we put out a video to go through the comments
And see what people say
Yeah
Do they like it? Do they hate it?
Do they...
What do they like about it?
Yeah, what do they like about it?
And have that
Engagement
And that's what actually makes YouTube really cool
Is because it allows you to do that immediately *snap*
So I really searched through the YouTube comments too to see
If anyone had questions that weren't being answered
Or just kinda overlook
One major thing that I saw a lot is
How exactly do you guys make money?
Because you do -
I ask myself that everyday.
You do upload, y'know, very high quality videos
That on average break a million view mark
So how do you supply all of this
With all the salaries and all the, y'know
Yeah
Cos' I mean, you're a family man
How do you, exactly support all that with an actual income and salary
Totally, it's a good question
The first
And, I guess, most basic answer
Is that it's multiple different income streams
That are all based around the product
Of what we make here, which is video
In the beginning of every video there's an ad
So we make money, first and foremost, through that
That, in and of itself, is kind of it's own science
With YouTube, the basic rule is that minutes watched
Are your key factor to how much you get paid from it
But realistically we only get paid about 80 cents for every thousand people that watch the video
So the next part of that is the Sam and Niko videos
Which usually are a little bit longer
Something that's a little bit easier to shoot
And, generally, we get paid a little bit more from those
Than we do from the Corridor videos
What part of working in this field do you find most challenging?
Oh, that's a good question
Pace of...
...Creating videos
It's...
A challenge not in the sense that it's always hard
But in that there's always a new thing to be learned
And understanding that each time you go through the creative process
There's going to be something that you're gonna need to learn
And accepting that and then, like, building it into how you get to the end goal
Is really important
And it's challenging
But it's a good kind of challenge, y'know, it's a healthy kind of challenge
So that can be as simple as like trying to figure out a camera movement in this one shot
Sure
Or figuring out how to edit with footage that you don't have enough to tell
The original story
And having to go through the process of changing the edit to tell a different story
Than you originally sought out to
And then learning... that
And then how you apply it to what you do in the future
I mean, it comes in many different formats
But it's always there
And in an arts - in an artistic career
That will always be a truth
Attention to detail
Whatever you're good at you understand the technical side of how it works
And that's part of what makes you good at it
What is your routine?
Dedication
And consistency
How you work with other people
Going more into that creative partner sort of thing
Like once you understand the technical side and you're dedicated and you have a routine
Then the next thing, really, is to look for
Creative partners that you can
That you can work with
Because even though there may not be the people in your...
Area, or in your everday situation
Eventually if you continue to reach out and
Don't be shy about it you will find people that
That work well with you
You never wanna live in a creative vacuum
It's always important to have your own creative identity
And to understand creatively what YOU want
And listen to your creative voice
And follow that
But it's always great to have people that you can
Bounce ideas off of, people that you can creatively collaborate with
And people that bring other skill sets to the table
That you might not necessarily have
When you're younger and you want to make art, it's all about
**** the man
That's where the core of a lot of creative inspiration comes from
The way that all art is supported
Is by commercial
So it's very...
It's a very interesting thing about Western Society
Back in the Greek and Roman days
Artists would be commissioned by
the Emperors, or the kings, or the Government
To create art
But in the United States at least we don't have a system for that
So all art is supported by commercial enterprise
It's a little bit of a Catch 22
In the sense that you wanna create something that's unique and you wanna own it and
You want it to be original but at the same time it has to be relate able
And it has to be sell able
And you always wanna find out where that is, and it's totally okay to sometimes be like
"You know what? I just wanna make this and get it out there"
"It's a creative thing I have inside of me"
"I don't care if anyone likes it"
And you just wanna make it and get it out there -- That's totally awesome and fine
Film school vs. Just kinda going out and learning how to do it
Some people choose to go to film school, some people choose to
Go out and just... go at it
And try to create things and put 'em out there
There's no wrong answer, I think
There's a different path for everybody
Sounds like you're kinda taking an approach - a blended approach to it
Which I think that, personally I think that's pretty smart
Just going "Well if we do what..."
"We feel is fun and interesting"
Then it'll... by virtue of that be original and...
And hopefully it'll have a niche
That nobody else has, and that's what we set out to do and I think...
Anyone that's ever making anything should always approach it that way, y'know
You have your influences
But at the end of the day you have, ah
What you make and as long as you just try to stay true to that
It comes through
That's pretty good
Sweet man. Well, thank you for coming down
Yup, thank you Jake
Really appreciate your time and I appreciate you coming down here
And representing everyone out there who's looking to start a career as an artist
I'm gonna get a lot of hate mail
*Jake Wheeze Laugh*
The idea that television is an expendable form I believe needs to be eradicated.
Because the anatomy of the televisual medium
Is endowed with methods of story telling unobtainable in film
For example, the clearest benefit of a serialized story
Is length.